an ounce torie about a little boy whose
art has become you could say a major
draw these pictures are the work of
ten-year-old Joe whale
he loves to doodle don't we all on any
blank page that he can find he's even
gotten in trouble with his teachers for
it but while others saw a habit his
parents saw a talent yeah they did and
now he's got tens of thousands of fans
and Lee met this young artist in
Shrewsbury England for Joe whale these
aren't merely doodles
it's his imagination coming to life
what's your favorite thing to do I like
robots and aliens the ten-year-old
discovered his passion for drawing in a
familiar place your math book turned
into a book but you might guess his
teacher didn't take too kindly to this
yeah your doodling at school and the
teacher says there's no doodling at
school yeah how'd that feel
well it made me feel quite annoying
because there was no place that I really
be able to express myself so Joe's
parents Greg and Vanessa decided
something must be done we thought would
just get him into some after-school
class those art classes soon led to
Joe's first big commission a wall at a
local restaurant I was really excited
because it was the first time I can
actually express myself and pretend that
my characters were coming to life the
wall was a hit and requests well they
started to roll in for more doodles and
his Instagram account it hit over 19,000
followers in just a few days it's just
overwhelming so we have to shield him
from that and Joe has no idea the scale
of what it's turned into so we're just
protecting him as much as we can from
that so he can just enjoy drawing well
Joe's parents managed his future he has
his own vision what do you want to be
when you grow up definitely an artist it
sounds like you really want to make your
art so people can enjoy it
so this is that famous wall and it got
me thinking that your studio in New York
could use something so Joe doodle this
portrait up y'all on my camera man zoom
in just a bit so you get a better look
at it but Joe really hopes you like it
nicely done Ian and go well it would be
fun to have him come in here and do our
wall we have the same looks great behind
us he becomes famous Roberto thanks Ali